all aim was talking about after the
finale was a plastic water bottle that
was spotted in one of the final scenes
is there's a picture of it right here
that's the water bottle poking out
behind Sam's leg yes and then of course
this comes after a coffee cup was
spotted in an earlier episode this year
and people all talked about that well
guess what to take advantage of this we
apparently I just found this up for the
show we have a new sponsor and this
sponsor is cashing in on this phenomenon
a game of thrones with a really cool
product check it out now that game of
thrones has ended fans the world over
are left wondering how to fill the void
were worried not introducing the game of
Thrones
accidental beverage cameo collector set
now you can buy such well known
accidental beverages as the coffee cup
scene in front of Daenerys the water
bottle behind Sam's leg in the finale
the can of squirter Raven landed on in
season 1 episode 10 remember the
chocolate milk held by the night king
that green smoothie someone left on Ned
Stark severed head the famous battle
were every warrior had a McFlurry then
of course this iconic scene
[Music]
only law in the game of Thrones
accidental beverage cameo collector sin
get yours now at participating medieval
times restaurants
[Applause]